hey guys i am katherine mccourt i'm so
excited that we're here today because
this is pro tips from pro
chefs
i am the founder of welicious m1 potato
and i'm going to be sharing
a recipe i absolutely love there are a
ton of different tips involved in this
one
it is healthy delicious really easy
only one piece of equipment that's the
airfryer we're
making vegetables in an airfryer aka air
fried veggies the best part about it
no matter the season whether you're at
the farmer's market or the grocery
you can take any kind of vegetables and
use it in
this recipe but if you are in the winter
you could use
winter squash you could use pumpkins
again carrots
onions like the world is your oyster
if you're used to roasting vegetables
forget it it is
all about air frying them to start
again just grabbing like any of your
favorite vegetables
just give them a good little wash and
the trick to this is you want to make
sure to cut them
in even sized pieces but you can see
that like out sometimes i'll even just
pull these little florets just like this
because sometimes i like little ones and
i like bigger pieces
uh and so that's all we're doing with
the cauliflower and like
make it wild and crazy grab purple
cauliflower yellow white
like it's fun to get a bunch of
different vegetables
because that's where you're going to get
this really vibrant assortment
so now i've got the little patty pan
squash and i'll just cut them
right in half just like that and then
this one is a little bit bigger
so i'll take off the top just pull off
that little stem i'm going to put that
to the side
um and then we're just going to quarter
these and they get
really like crispy on the outside super
tender inside and then like i said like
see how this chunk
is very similar we ordered that one
they're about even sized
and then a carrot so you think of like a
carrot really
hard crunchy but when it's in an air
fryer it's just gonna get like
really tender and the natural sweetness
from the carrot gets caramelized and it
is like
next level i just cut these into batons
but you could also cut them into
coins like big coins if you want um you
know what let's go wild and crazy let's
let's cut a few coins and we'll
cut a few batons and this is a great way
like look if you guys have kids
get your kids in pull in a board um you
know
summer time give them a kids safe knife
and let them help cut vegetables
that's a great way to get them to kind
of snack on them at the same time
look at that all colors textures shapes
sizes and what we're going to do is just
open the airfryer right up and put this
in i'm going to actually pull out my
basket because this is one of those pro
tips i've been talking about
so you have your empty air fryer right
here
and i'm just going to take my vegetables
and put them right in
what i love about this is that we don't
even have to get
another bowl out uh to wash and have to
deal with and clean because
your airfryer basket is gonna act as
your bowl
so go ahead and this is another pro tip
i love to take a spray
so you could use olive oil canola oil
ghee spray
that i've got here anything because
what's great about the spray
is that it evenly just kind of kisses
each
nook and cranny of the vegetables so
it's going to get these like nice
golden bits making them really crispy on
the outside
but soft and tender inside so then we're
going to take a little bit of salt
i like to do some kosher salt here but
you could also get in some pepper
open up your spice drawer do not ignore
your spice drawer this is the time to
pull out like
some cumin some curry garam masala
any kind of like spices that you've been
like dying
um to play around with this is the time
to use them
now i just give it a little bit of a
shake so put it right in the air fryer
click it on air fry we're gonna we're
gonna
actually turn the temperature down with
vegetables i like to do
somewhere between 375 and 400 today
we're going to go like 400
um and go any you know this is one thing
that you want to just keep an eye on i
like to do 20 minutes especially for
cauliflower and carrots they're a little
bit harder we want to make them more
tender
so go ahead and give it a little bit of
time you may need to pull out some
vegetables
a little bit earlier than others it
makes a delicious side
you could make in an entree by putting a
little bit of hummus on the side one of
my favorite summertime recipes
is to take my air fried vegetables with
lettuce like really nice crunchy lettuce
a nice vinaigrette and you're gonna have
an air fried vegetable salad
that will make anyone in your life crazy
happy belly's filled healthy delicious
and really easy again i'm katherine
mccord you can find me
licious at one potato box and if you
make this recipe which i hope you do
don't forget to share it on at drew
barramore show
and hashtag drew barramore show so we
can find what you're making in your
kitchen this summer